I don't want to open a blocked
account to open my study visa.
How can I dodge it?
Well, there are alternatives in Germany,
for example,
the alternative Eve is a full scholarship,
the scholarship from a university,
government or private organization.
Can it even be a company that fully fund you,
your accommodation,
living expenses
which is blocked account
and your tuition fees at the university.
Then you don't have to open a blocked account.
The second option
and it's actually the second and the last option
is for fleece to declare on,
it's the German word for an invitation.
It has to be an invitation from your friend or relative
that has been leaving in Germany for a while
and has visa or passport for the next few years
duration of your education
and is earning minimum 2 thousand four hundred
2,500 before taxes per month.
Condition is to not sponsor anybody else but you.
So you should be the first one and the only one
and with that invitation,
no blocked account required.
But keep in mind
not every person is gonna give you that invitation
because that invitation says that if something happens,
they are responsible for all the things you do
and if you're in financial trouble,
they have to pay it.
So ask these people in advance
if that's something they would agree to.
If there's anything else you would like to ask,
please feel free to contact me anytime
and I'll be happy. To help.